ladies and gentlemen dear friends
i'm glad to join you at the women
political leaders summit today
it is inspiring to be among so many
female parliamentarians
from across the world to discuss a topic
which could not be more timely
how can we ensure that when we come out
of the crisis
our societies will be not only more
digital
not only more sustainable but also
more inclusive because this pandemic has
exposed
not only the fragility of our health
and our livelihoods it has also exposed
the fragility of our societies
when it comes to equality and women's
rights
and the united nations even warns that
the pandemic could set women back
decades in their struggle for equality
dear friends as women political leaders
we have to make sure that this will not
happen i have been first
the first woman in a job several times
in my life
as so many of you have also been we have
all made our various experiences
and we know change does not come
automatically and this is why
last spring for example the commission
presented its first
ever gender equality strategy
with this strategy we want to ensure
equal opportunities in the labor market
and achieve gender balance in decision
making and
in politics we lead through action
and we lead by example some of you might
know
that for the first time in history the
european commission
of which i have the honor to be
president has as many female members
as male this was long overdue
we now want to repeat this success
at the middle and senior management
levels
women already hold more than 40 of the
top
positions in the european commission
i have set a target of 50 by the end of
2024
because our democracies are stronger
when women are involved as equals
not because women are better but because
we are different
to see the world in fully rounded way we
need men
and women this is the only way
we will be able to make the right
decisions
and to maximize our success both of our
societies
and economies dear friends as women
leaders
we have to make sure that we get the
respect we are due
and the treatment appropriate for our
position
just as our male colleagues do
and we have to speak up whenever this is
not
the case we owe this to ourselves
and above all to others because whatever
happens to us
is immediately brought to public
attention
but what about the millions of women who
do not have this advantage
women who are heard every day in every
corner of our planet
but hold neither the power nor the
office to speak up
we have to make sure that their stories
are also told and then acted upon
and this is the mission i see for us at
this very particular moment
to foster a more equal society as we
come out of this pandemic
and to continue our fight for those who
cannot
make themselves hurt let me say again
i'm so glad to be with you today and i
wish you a fruitful meeting
thank you